the conflict in South Sudan has taken
almost everything from these people they
had no choice but to take refuge in this
camp it's mostly women and children that
have come here seeking a safety away
from the violence and something to eat
mornings have been very bad since the
fighting broke out we have no food and
we have to survive on wild berries and
roots experts say the food shortages in
South Sudan and now among the most acute
in the world and could lead to the worst
famine in decades and there's no sign
the country's civil war will end soon it
has already hindered farmers from
planting crops that means the situation
is likely to get worse in the coming
months it's intensified bombing and
fighting during the planting season may
june and july is likely to have an
impact on the harvest and family's
ability to feed themselves the UN has
already warned that 50,000 children are
at risk of dying from malnutrition this
year alone the UN says around a billion
dollars is needed to prevent a major
humanitarian crisis